foreign
is next up hi Chris how are you great
how are you better than I deserve what's
up
um so as you're aware The Total Money
Makeover was published in 2003
and I'm sure you're also aware that the
first baby step is to save a thousand
dollars to our emergency fund so my
question since the book has been
released for 20 years and with a current
dramatic rise in inflation do you still
feel a thousand dollars is the correct
amount to start to be successful with
your plan
a thousand dollars was not enough in
2003.
[Applause]
it was never designed to be enough it's
enough to buy an alternator for a car or
a tire maybe one or two uh it's enough
to uh take your kid to the pediatrician
if they're sick but it's not enough to
be a real emergency fund it's enough to
keep the little things from kicking your
butt off the get out of debt wagon
because what we when we first started
this stuff years ago I just I said use
all your savings have zero
and that didn't work honestly that and
if you had come to Financial Peace
University when I was teaching it with
an overhead projector before we had the
baby steps I just was Hardcore just you
know I'm like you're in boot camp shut
up sell everything use all your money
don't whine get your butt out of debt
because if you don't get out of debt
none of this is going to work and but we
discovered pretty quickly that every
little thing that came along that wasn't
in their little budget the first few
months knock them out knock them out
knock them out and then they would give
up hope the people in financial piece
would give up hope because they couldn't
do the system the system wasn't working
so we decide okay we're gonna give you
just a little bit of a beginner starter
emergency fund just to knock the little
stuff off if you have a car transmission
go out it's not enough if you have
something big happen it's not enough
it's not designed to be enough it's just
there and and to cover while you'd go
through the typically it's about 18
months out of the 10 million people have
been through Financial Peace University
it's 18 months to get out of debt not
counting your house baby step two now
that means some of them do it in three
months and some of them do it in 30 but
the average is 18. so it's designed just
to keep the little crap away but if if
your car blows up during that 18 months
it's not enough and it never was
designed to be enough so it doesn't need
to be a inflation adjusted because it
wasn't supposed to be enough but good
question thank you sir
I just want to say something very quick
about inflation because that's all we
hear about it makes you click and that's
what the media is supposed to do but
understand that the reason why inflation
is stubborn folks is now wage pressures
and that's fancy economic language that
I barely understand but it means that
hourly rates and salaries at our an
all-time high and the reason why your
Burger King combo or your bread costs
more is because they're paying the
person in those positions at Burger King
and the grocery store more so when I
hear that question I think it's a good
question but let's also understand that
we the people still have tremendous
individual responsibility and power to
see in this economy where we have about
four and a half million more jobs
available than there are people who are
unemployed and right now in the gig
economy which means I go out and do
something part-time and freelance
economy there is more opportunity to
make really good money so if you're
gazelle intense and at a thousand
dollars isn't enough you go make use of
more money and pay for that all
alternator you can go make plenty of
money in this economy right now that's a
great Point Ken
and on top of that the Ken makes a great
Point people don't think about okay
let's walk through that worst case
scenario you have an emergency that's
more than a thousand dollars what do you
do we tell you to pause the baby steps
and stack up cash really quickly and
most people doing the plan they didn't
have much more than a thousand to begin
with and so this hypothetical scenario
where they had so much money could cover
all these emergencies it just doesn't
exist if we made the emergency fund and
baby step one five thousand dollars we
would have a tiny portion of the
population be able to do that and have
the hope and motivation to continue but
Chris's question if you were going to
say the plan is let's say we got to baby
step three and instead of saying three
to six months of expenses we said ten
thousand dollars or fifteen thousand
dollars in 2003 now today would we need
to say okay that's not correct anymore
we would need to adjust it because it's
not enough if it if it was enough in
2003 to have a fifteen thousand dollar
baby step three it's not enough in 2023.
so his his concept is valid but it
doesn't apply to baby step one and the
good news is is that the other baby
steps are not fixed amounts that's the
only one that's a fixed amount the rest
of them are percentages
and so they flow out of that percentage
and the percentages will adjust with
inflation and with wage pressures and
with everything else so you know okay a
million dollars isn't what it used to be
in your retirement account true
but we million dollars is just a
milestone it wasn't the only target we
said put 15 away and maybe step four and
hopefully 10 million is what you get you
know I mean uh so you know it's adjusted
that way uh and so three to six months
of expenses your expenses have changed
since 2003 they should have yeah and so
your emergency fund would need to be
bigger today your baby step three one so
his concept is accurate in questioning a
number a fixed number from 2003 but it
also gives me the opportunity to explain
that baby step one wasn't ever designed
to be that in the first place because I
get the you know some of these idiots on
Tic Tac or whatever that are
um you know Dave Ramsey doesn't know
what he's talking about his stuff's
outdated yeah that's right that's how
you know the law of gravity is now
outdated
so
but Dave you've you've told people on
air before you've have you tweaked that
thousand dollar number based on a very
specific situation
where you went all right fine you can do
1500 you could do 500.
you know what are the scenarios the
other thing I realized is that uh
uh this didn't you know none of these
baby steps came from the Bible they came
from our experiences
of coaching thousands of people and uh
so they're not absolute truth in that
sense uh they're they're based on
Concepts that are absolute truth but
they're not the baby steps themselves
are not magical all they are is a clear
path and everybody needs a clear path to
do whatever they're going to do Ken
teaches a clear path to get into a new
position in a step-by-step process
you've got to have a clear path you know
if you get ready to go to college and
you want to graduate there's a clear
path it's called a syllabus take the
freaking classes get the degree you know
there's a clear path you know what you
have to do to get there and so winning
always involves a clear path and a
process so that part and I'm aware
George that somebody's going to decide
to do whatever they want to do because
they're like grown-ups and stuff but uh
but I'm not going to vary on the air
because every time we vary on the air we
we not only vary for that single person
that's on the that's what we're talking
to but 22 million other people are
listening and so then you start to blow
up the whole idea and the beauty of the
baby steps of the clear path including
the one that Ken uses is uh we don't
vary from it because it it and then
people start to believe it because it's
a proven path it's a proven system and
if you submit yourself to a proven
system then you can you can hit those
goals so it's a good it's a really good
discussion everyone thinks they're
special everyone thinks they're unique
they're the outlier you know like well
Dave you don't understand my situation
you are but that doesn't exclude you
from the law of gravity yeah yeah that's
right yeah I'm special you're going to
hit the sidewalk shut up I mean it's
like you know that's it I mean you're
not you're special but you're not you
know that we all are I mean you're
unique you have unique situations and
that's what makes the show interesting
people calling in with unique uh family
life and unique situations you're going
that's cray-cray you know it's
entertaining you know and but the
principles that we guide Our Lives by
um you know like you all told a young
guy there you know be sure you apologize
early and often that's a great principle
okay does it apply every single time no
I don't need to apologize to my wife if
she runs over me with a car you know
it's her fault you know that's a very
specific scenario no but I'm just trying
to think of something bizarre right you
know somebody misbehaving you know so
but but but is apologizing a good
principle you bet it is quickly early
and often you bet it is it's a wonderful
it's a sign of a strength of confidence
of humility it's a you know it's weak
people they can't apologize it requires
courage so it's a you know those are
those are simple things but these simple
Concepts do apply universally this is
the Ramsey Show